[Music]
in Mo Money mo problems news oh yeah
submitted by Richard Quan son of art
Quan not now
amen your name could be name like Dante
or something ago yeah sean tizzle yeah
a man sues his parents for more money
after blowing two million of their
lottery winnings how do you sue your
parents for money I don't [ __ ]
understand this [ __ ] I don't taste them
for all that money how do you sue
how do you see your parents maybe they
were shitty [ __ ] I wish for you
do but how do you sue that I don't
understand all like legally like how
does that happen
like why would you want to sue them like
why would like what do they owe you
I guess if they [ __ ] you over in a deal
like business partners that makes sense
some kids are just so entitled maybe I
would how do you and how old is this
[ __ ] you don't want to know dirty
you don't want to know cleaning it very
angry
don't make me faint like a [ __ ]
18th century damsel in distress right
tell you is a the show some manners
this is either light problems or Chinese
problems are you stay white white oh how
did you know that because only white
people got that much money
yeah because only white people to each
other in the family and then these new
waves of Chinese [ __ ] they
behave crazy to be this must be in the
UK yes how did you know the teeth
exactly oh because it looks like darling
and he looks like he looks like a UK
bodyguard or some sort yeah she's like a
whole Jason Bourne racism is actually a
time decision another note it down I
just heard the story white UK but we
don't even know the story it's actually
a actual science that yes it's broken
down you guys are really good at this my
god look at the [ __ ] colour on this
[ __ ] huge I've never seen that before
brother Church it's you little awesome
so this is the bad in the stepmom for
security to all and there's a lottery
winners Dave and ng they want 101
million British pounds which is about
150 million u.s. dollars hope you don't
go bankrupt how can I find a little bit
of X on the floor mm-hmm I don't can't
stop looking on the floor babe that's
probably a problem a lot of lottery
tickets tomorrow
said that for years I don't want it I
changed my mind
I don't wanna hundred thirty million
dollars don't I do I want to work for it
I was about 100 your birthday I'll give
it back
no gives me no seriously I don't I want
[ __ ] I want to work for someone came to
you with a briefcase full of 130 million
dollars you're gonna open angrily I
don't want it I didn't work 130 million
dollars I could change all of your lives
right yeah here's an all electric force
you must he will document on my behalf
and I give you the money you don't have
to do any of that all I give me the
money and then give me more money to not
forget it you are it's a [ __ ]
curse because you're gonna be happy for
the first maybe year but there's a curse
behind it mm-hmm
there is that a lot I'll just share the
curse with everybody that's close to me
it's called added an earnest and I
change my whole entire life
and I thought I'll be happy with all
this new [ __ ] but I'm not curse I think
you know what part did I think like the
cool thing is is I've worked enough you
got it like you feel like you deserve it
already I think if I got this it would
just change my perspective on how I live
life because number one but only like
cool things at a quote unquote like is
like camera [ __ ] right other than that
is not much and it's not what really
makes me happy is like buying new things
it's just having new experiences and I
think with that said the money you can
have new experiences constantly to the
day you [ __ ] die you know okay I want
it I know you will enjoy it very much
too because like I think like the office
life is Amina suits you so magical her
thirty million dollars dude you could do
whatever you want outside for as long as
you want and you'll be okay
the
and if I don't if my friends have work
I'll just be like how much does your job
pay I just pay your salary come with me
hmm do I check no Cathy with you I need
to do this movie well tell your boss I
said shut the [ __ ] up and slap them in
the face with the money
points are you giving the boss some
money yeah there's Tommy shut the [ __ ]
up I call it's coming from these two
that have no bosses look at our time our
friends who have bosses I have come hang
out with us I know you guys want to come
hang out with us
duh see we give the money to tip and she
slaps us with it doesn't million dollars
think how are the awesome that's the
only problem another slapping of many
others videos it the the money part
where she has to wipe your Dookie on it
and then smack them in the face not me
go get a job go get a job or get a job
oh that's a viral video see we just make
more money with these ideas if to slap
me in the face of the million dollars
cover to do viral video
Sam come down do that but my money money
makes more money now you guys need to
see the Sun yeah Oh 32 year old Michael
didn't look like best friend ah why does
that one look like someone awfully guy I
thought he was the dad when I initially
saw it because there was a side-by-side
photo
so smaller and I thought he was the son
that his father [ __ ] Benjamin Button
[ __ ] himself bug that was old so came
out as one with cataracts is yes it was
gross so Michael here and his partner
James okay yeah I mr. James
whoa he's a good-looking guy yes the
rising of some active Adam and his name
Chico is my brother like use a trophy
gay guy like that's the trophy gay guy
boyfriend right and then he's like a
rich like gay guy I wasn't if the
boyfriend is a lawyer
oh I don't know so he's likely a you
know that Michael
he quit a very well-paying IT job once
his father won the lottery that's his
fault [ __ ] [ __ ] earn your own money
[ __ ]
my mom wins the lottery half my mom do
whatever the [ __ ] you want to I'm gonna
take her [ __ ] I'm just gonna wait till
she dies and then it comes to me yeah
and by the way what does your father
winning 131 million dollars has to do
with your pockets yeah well and your
jobbing are like maybe the des Hold'em
equip so when the dad initially won the
lottery
he gave a million to his sign and he was
like you know what he said something
along the lines of like you know now
you're going to be good kind of thing so
Michael is saying that he took that as
like he's going to financially support
me for the rest of my life and so that's
why [ __ ] did he say that [ __ ] yeah he's
cute whatever the dad was telling him
and so Michael and James Etienne was
London Fog his ear holes
London [ __ ] gonna [ __ ] him here mmm
so like Michael and his boyfriend like
they lived a really lavish kind of
lifestyle where they bought a five
hundred fifty thousand pound house and
they gave about 250,000 pounds to
friends and James's family why that's
really [ __ ] up they just kept spending
it they were even spending 30,000 pounds
a month like just on their lifestyle and
then two thousand pound horse you're
gonna run out of sports investor exactly
and then a thousand pounds on groceries
a week so it's like so much music not
eating exactly and then so finally I got
to a point where Michael team like you
went to his dad to ask for more money I
named a Miami
yeah so then his dad was like okay well
and so he transferred more money to his
account or I'll hide it up to about
600,000 more Wow like 1.6 million pounds
I he gave his son she's making the anger
continue but dad's actually pretty money
savvy could even with a hundred and
thirty million which is a lot 101 pounds
under one like 101 like pounds millions
whatever he still give him the kid like
small and not 1% yeah in comparison to
what he has because he probably
understands like a million dollars how
the [ __ ] did you blow that yeah crazy if
my parents won that and they even gave
me a million bucks I would do wow I was
letting my dad good I know I was you
like what you like in Dick's I'm like no
you don't have to do that at all like
thank you
you know man on you this suit is so
ungrateful so that is what I'm not
asking for a [ __ ] and you're just
like where do I suck
it's the confucian gratitude you just
are some buckling the bill towards no
weight so he spent all this within like
what was a time spent
it was pretty quickly go I think like
within two years oh my god fast
that's crazy so then after he spent all
the money there was a birthday party for
Angie the stepmom that he went to and
all he brought with flowers but then he
tells the judge well would you give
someone it has everything but that's
inside the partisan class makes them to
from the heart yeah yeah so then I at
that birthday party Michael was like
really rude to angie handed up being
like verbally abusive towards her he was
demanding five million pounds more from
them so then that's when they were like
okay
Yoriko here you're done and then they
cut him out this is been a moment
oh you think they sued him and they got
a certain amount of money no they didn't
okay there's something them no no no so
the Sun is doing the father because the
son feels entitled okay I'm sure here oh
you meant babes with him and James yeah
I'm sorry yes so so then be went to
court all this and then
reason why this is you now because the
court concluded that the court what
everyone was George Washington which has
what I pictured to another so this is
what the judge said
Michael was provided with the funds to
have a comfortable life but for his own
reasons he chose not to take that
opportunity I therefore dismissed this
claim
nice oh yeah so [ __ ] waste time you
[ __ ]
I don't laugh sack of [ __ ] [ __ ] and
it's crazy because obviously that kid
was not a kid I'm sorry he got old yeah
well dad Matt he's like what
30-something years old right he's worked
hard to have a very high-paying job but
his behavior is like a child rim yeah so
it's I don't understand that like
doesn't make any sense for me because
like once you get that money [ __ ]
but that covers your regular basis the
rest that income is now yours
like the one that you work for like it's
just yours to play with them yeah so
this will get a million and then he
asked daddy to rescue gets like more he
gets two point something million in
total and he still asked for more
what a [ __ ] dick what yeah oh because
I followed him I would stay at IT or
maybe do part-time doing what I want to
do like you know it's always been a
dream mine to be like a surfer part-time
so and teach surf classes or whatever
maybe he does that like he teaches surf
classes part-time but he just sits on
the money puts it in investments and
then boom you know get a couple thousand
dollars a month and lives off of that I
wish my uncle would win the lottery
already why does your uncle buy a lot of
lottery tickets been like family it's
been like 40 years he's are doing
non-stop Mike raffle playing like 10
years straight number one yeah every
single day what about a little war did
he win a little bit that I do not know
there was one like here never never even
zone unless you win it big you know I'd
be so excited
if any of us did it we should start
doing those like pools again that was so
exciting it was a long time that one
time on the Powerball was like three
hundred million and we all joined in
we're already like starting to think of
what to do yeah I just felt sad because
in my heart I do you want yeah
we lost that's why I felt we did win we
won like seven bucks and then I got
invested in another lottery ticket I
felt stupid because I mean like I said
when we didn't win I felt like I was
spit off I feel like I was cheated like
I was supposed to win I was already
cloudy that time that already I was so
sure we were all gonna win and we were
gonna I would you say when $100,000
that'd be [ __ ] fantastic it's awesome
mm-hmm
that's like some good much I'd have been
cooler $50 hey guys hope you enjoyed
that episode please don't miss a beat
and subscribe to the pedo subscribe you
don't know when a new video is uploaded
but for more videos click up here
[Music]